[Music]
Leonardo DiCaprio didn't actually have
to fight a real-life bear for his role
in the Revenant but he still left the
shoot a changed man from physical trials
to emotional challenges his time filming
the Epic tale of survival turned out to
be quite the ordeal
shooting the Revenant was a painful
experience for everyone involved the
cast was left exposed to a cold hostile
landscape and conditions were so
unbearable that many of the crew members
couldn't quit fast enough Leonardo
DiCaprio had never experienced anything
like it before as an actor even spending
hours working in giant tanks of water
for Titanic felt like a breeze compared
to dragging himself through snow in a
wet bare skin when the film was finally
released the shooting conditions got
just as much Buzz as the film itself
after all it was hard to believe that it
was possible for Hollywood actors to
work in such a harsh environment
ain't afraid to die anymore
I'm done already
DiCaprio described this particular role
as the epitome of pain speaking about
director Alejandro ineritu he told the
telegraph from the outset Alejandro had
an extraordinary Vision to create a film
the likes of which audiences had never
seen before you don't get those sort of
results without going above and beyond
the Call of Duty for DiCaprio pushing
himself so hard for the sake of his
craft was certainly a transformative
experience daily life and normal
civilization must feel a bit too easy
and shallow in comparison
as soon as shooting for the Revenant was
finally over DiCaprio was ready to take
some time off for himself there was no
doubt that he wanted to relax and
physically recover as his body probably
needed it he didn't want to Dive Right
into whatever his next role would be
without taking a sabbatical of sorts
there was plenty of talk about what his
next move would be after winning that
well-deserved oscar but DiCaprio was in
no rush to get back in front of the
camera just yet in fact he wouldn't act
again for several years his next film
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood wouldn't
be released until 2019. considering
DiCaprio's star power a couple of years
off didn't hurt his career in any way he
could come back whenever he wanted and
still have his pick of amazing offers
and thankfully for audiences he has
when Leonardo DiCaprio isn't acting he's
spending plenty of time in the field of
environmental activism ever since his
early twenties the actor has been
interested in using his platform to
advocate for sustainability and raise
public awareness about climate change in
1998 he met with former vice president
Al Gore to discuss protecting endangered
species and he began donating Millions
to the cause while filming the Revenant
the cast and crew was forced to witness
the effects of climate change up close
they had originally planned to shoot in
Canada but they had to switch to
Argentina instead because there simply
wasn't enough snow up north at the time
2015 was the hottest year in Global
history as DiCaprio said to the
telegraph we are actually seeing the
Tipping Point happen right now it was
one thing to hear about global warming
but seeing it in person made him want to
confront the dire situation head on it
is hard to understand how some still
refuse to accept the reality of climate
change
there are two major themes in the
Revenant the first yes nature is
beautiful but it's brutal and we need to
respect that it's unforgiving the second
human beings have always been brutal to
each other stepping into the shoes of
Hugh glass deeply affected DiCaprio and
made him realize that this aspect of
human nature hasn't disappeared in
modern times we may be more peaceful and
tolerant towards each other on average
but that destructive tendency can still
be seen in the way we treat the natural
world chopping down forests burning
fossil fuels polluting the environment
building over animals habitats and
ignoring the rising temperatures and sea
levels in favor of endless growth it's
all taking a serious toll as DiCaprio
put it in an interview with timeout you
look back at that time in the Revenant
and this surge West extracting resources
from nature killing off indigenous
Native American tribes cutting down the
trees and digging for oil and you think
oh my god look how brutal we were we are
destroying nature and killing species at
a rate that is unprecedented
how would you even come back to the real
world after taking a part in a film like
the Revenant it might make it more
difficult to relate to other people and
it would probably make you consider your
connection to Nature and reflect on your
place in the universe it's certainly not
a stretch to say that DiCaprio probably
felt like working on this particular
film was a spiritual exercise looking
back on the Revenant DiCaprio said it
felt like a dream and he remarked that
he essentially remembers it as a big
beautiful blur DiCaprio has also
referred to his environmental activism
as a form of spirituality he told
timeout I love being immersed in nature
going to places in the world that are
pristine and Untouched by man it's
almost a religious experience when you
go to a place like the Amazon and
there's no civilization to thousands of
miles clearly working on the Revenant
encouraged DiCaprio to think about the
ways we're all connected to each other
and our planet they may not be a
religious person but he certainly has a
spiritual side now
what else was Leonardo DiCaprio working
on while filming the Revenant to say
that he was stretching himself thin
would be an understatement around the
same time he also captured the effects
of climate change around the world with
his documentary Before the Flood
creating the documentary took three
years total during which DiCaprio spent
time talking with activists politicians
entrepreneurs and concerned citizens he
even included some discussion about the
conditions on the set of the Revenant
it's really a conversation about the
urgency of taking action on climate
change Before the Flood got great
reviews and many people seemed
pleasantly surprised by the sincerity of
DiCaprio's message DiCaprio wanted to
focus on the most vulnerable victims of
climate change such as the people living
in low-lying island nations like
grihibas what really makes the
documentary Stand Out are the amazing
interviews only DiCaprio could get
Barack Obama Elon Musk and Pope in the
same documentary thanks to his decades
as an A-list actor Leonardo DiCaprio is
a multi-millionaire he could easily
retire tomorrow never work another day
in his life and get by just fine but for
him neither acting nor activism are
about fame or money he's not in it for
the praise the awards the publicity or
the dollar signs in fact the more
successful DiCaprio becomes the less he
cares about being rich or staying in the
spotlight especially after working on
the Revenant the actor knows that all
the money in the world won't make you
happy he told parade the idea of
pursuing material objects your whole
life is absolutely soulless Steve Jobs
sat on his deathbed talking about how
greed and wealth is the root problem of
everything I believe that too after
seeing firsthand how our pursuit of
material wealth has irreversibly altered
our planet it's easy to understand why
DiCaprio holds this point of view doing
anything just for the money will never
bring true satisfaction especially not
when the future of our entire planet is
in danger
yes acting will probably always be
DiCaprio's greatest passion but he also
has a deep-seated need to give back he
elaborated my career has given me so
much from a material standpoint I feel
that I absolutely need to give back in
whatever capacity I can it's my moral
obligation DiCaprio does face criticism
for his activism after all he has the
typical trappings of an ultra wealthy
lifestyle from a fancy yacht to a
private jet he's been called a hypocrite
plenty of times and even addressed it
head on and Before the Flood he
acknowledged that he sometimes wonders
if he's the best spokesperson for this
cause as he's well aware that there's
some truth to the accusations of
hypocrisy but at the end of the day
DiCaprio has a huge platform and the
ability to make people sit up and listen
as long as he's a public figure he's
going to use his status for good plenty
of people feel upset and depressed when
the subject of environmental issues and
climate change comes up after all it's
easy to feel helpless in the face of a
global problem but how do activists who
are constantly looking at this data
field predictably pessimism can easily
set in human beings are Innovative and
adaptable but moving towards a more
sustainable Society is going to take a
huge effort as a species DiCaprio
doesn't exactly have a Rosy Outlook
himself when it comes to climate change
he admitted that he felt very
pessimistic while he was filming Before
the Flood and this was probably
compounded when he saw the weather
conditions in Canada during his time
there for the Revenant it seems that
DiCaprio's uncertainty about the future
has altered his perspective on life
Leonardo DiCaprio finally returned to
the big screen with Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood but his efforts to educate the
public about potential climate change
Solutions didn't slow him down one bit
in 2019 he was featured in another
documentary this one titled Ice on fire
here DiCaprio explores what a green
future would actually look like and
instead of giving in to despair he
focuses on possible solutions it seems
that climate change will be just as
important to DiCaprio as acting for the
foreseeable future just because he's
talking about Solutions now doesn't mean
his work is over the Revenant was a
pivotal moment in DiCaprio's career and
it caused him to look at the world in a
whole new light